the second generation of the panamera
has been hitting the headlines as
porsche's first plug-in hybrid which can
be charged using a household electrical
socket the panamera sc hybrid's battery
stores five times as much power as its
predecessor and at 70 kilowatts its
electric motor is more than twice as
powerful
our reviewer says the panamera e-hybrid
is quiet as a mouse all you hear is the
tires rolling and the wind blowing the
car has a range of 36 kilometers in pure
electric mode though if driven prudently
it can travel more than 50. feinholt
says that's a quantum leap compared to
its predecessor which manages two
kilometers in electric mode
even when the battery is run down the
panamera doesn't have to be plugged into
a socket pressing the e-charge button
turns the electric motor into a
generator
then the gasoline engine drives not only
the wheels its energy is also used to
produce electricity
long drives on the highway can charge
the battery for short emissions
emissions-free jaunts around the city
feinhold is impressed by the way the
e-hybrid switch is almost imperceptibly
between gas and electric mode the boost
function packs the 95 horsepower of the
electric motor onto that of the
combustion engine this makes for 416
horsepower altogether allowing the car
to rocket from zero to 100 kilometers an
hour and 5.5 seconds and hit a top speed
of 270.
the new hybrid model delivers 306
kilowatts of power and generates a hefty
590 newton meters of torque but thanks
to the added electric motor fuel
consumption is just 3.1 liters per 100
kilometers in electric mode the se
hybrid can reach 135 kilometers an hour
not everyone likes the panamera's design
but those who do like it a lot
the rest tend to opt for a classic 911.
under the hood is a 3 liter v6 engine
that works in tandem with the electric
motor
striking lettering and the porsche
emblem on the wheels round off the
exterior
the battery can be recharged at home
thanks to some special equipment
in germany regular household electrical
sockets have between 8 and 10 amps of
current explains porsche's robot kayla
so it takes around 4 hours to charge the
battery fully
but if you have access to high voltage
current you can use that too then a full
charge takes two to three hours
the back end of the e-hybrid is also a
sight to behold and features led
taillights
the trunk can be opened by pressing a
button on the rear windshield wiper
it offers 335 liters of cargo space or 1
153 liters with the rear seat bench down
like the panamera gts the se hybrid uses
porsche's active suspension management
system or pasm it continuously regulates
the damping force for each wheel
according to the road conditions
inside the hybrid looks just like the
regular panamera say for one tiny detail
the writing on the rev counter
the s e hybrid is fitted with an eight
gear tiptronic s automatic transmission
the leather seats are comfortable and
ooze quality workmanship the ultimate in
luxury
clearly the se hybrid porsche isn't an
eco-friendly car for the masses its high
price tag means it's out of reach for
most the sedan can be had for 110 000
euros in germany but only if you resist
the many tempting optional extras